and of course something that I greatly
welcomed everybody there's been be
involved in trying to get shattered
justice at the enormous the
fourteen-year-old the ordeal needs to be
fact but let's remember Shakur armor has
been subjected to some of the worst
abuses in the war on terror he's been
held without charge or trial for almost
14 years he's been separated from his
four children and his wife all of whom
live in battersea in the UK the youngest
son Ferris has never seen his father and
the other children barely remember what
he even looks like in addition to that
shocker has witnessed two deaths of
three inmates in Guantanamo that were
allegedly suicides but he believes
otherwise he's had his head repeatedly
smashed against the wall in the presence
of British intelligence agents he's
witnessed other abuses which I think
will cause will cause very some
governments to shape would I think think
that he'll have to say and he's been
subjected to for seedings because he's
been on hunger strikes at various points
during his incarceration and that
force-feeding has essentially meant
having cubes forced them to his nose and
liquid food and jested into his stomach
moes am what was the latest report on
his health and well he's got better from
what I understand how to having smoked
his boys while back and so he is in a
better state than he was at the height
of the hunger strikes but nonetheless
and there have been various abuses that
there have been challenging the
prisoners there and essentially the
greatest abuse is being held without
charge or trial and this year there have
been several releases and several
announcements of releases by the US
regarding Guantanamo and I think that
Obama is trying slowly but surely to
follow through on his promise that he
made in 2000 month at Guantanamo close
shackle remember has never been trialed
tried has never been designated for
trial by military commission and this in
fact is is it his detention in
Guantanamo has been essentially a false
imprisonment from from what your
experience was what will happen I mean
we don't have a date or anything yes as
to when he who will actually be in the
UK but what will happen to him
immediately on arrival here it varies
from it the experiences are very good
for the various quantum a prisoner to
release to the UK in my case i returned
to RS nor falter
taken to Paddington Green police station
arrested briefly and then released to
the custody of our families i think in
chakras case what he will need it is
people who understand that the process
he's had had had 14 years of great much
of which has been in solitary
confinement so the last thing he needs
is to be arrested or to eat questioned
or to be put through something that he's
been put through a numerous time
sometimes possibly in with a gun with
his head he needs to be dealt with
sympathetically as a human being he
needs to be able to connect with his
family needs to be given space and even
the media and everybody else who's been
supporting in this case need to give him
that that that distance in order for him
to try to just understand what he's
coming back to because 14 years of cages
and dogs and military uniforms and guns
and then walking to the streets of
Britain he will have been in Turkish op
things have moved on so much the
internet mobile phones smartphones and
things are the things we've never dealt
with before and he will really need time
and effort and yes to reconnect with all
of them and the psychological impacts
the the ramifications are presumably
well lifelong they'll never go away I
think that he will I still to this day
see to the Guantanamo in my dreams and
in my nightmares I think him for him to
walk out and to walk into the freedom I
think what I understand of him he's a
very strong character he's somebody who
has a great deal to contribute to
himself to his family into his community
but it's going to take a long while
psychologically physically and otherwise
by him to be able to to integrate to
rehabilitate with his family and beyond
Mose am how how much is it in the for
mind of you might it be for schacher to
clear your name and I mean the
associations with Guantanamo are always
going to be there but to constantly go
out there and say this is who I am
that's not who I was well chapter
already brought a began this process
from insight on tumblr by his blares he
bit an article bit of a pittance
broadsheets in the UK i anit interviews
have been conducted by his lawyers for
the BBC and other media organizations in
which he said
and described who he is let's remember
the chatter has never been charged with
a crime despite the fact that he's being
interrogated by the CIA by the FBI by
the mi5 by British intelligence and
American intelligence so he's not the
criminal the crime has been committed
against him and that's what people need
to understand he if he if he had
committed a crime he would have been
charged by now as other people who go on
to animal happy and you've talked about
it you've written about it a great deal
it is there an urgency in your mind will
there be in his for some sort of justice
for those what wouldn't as you say is
nearly 14 years of his life well there's
two aspects to this one is that the
United States held him so there's been
no accountability out of the almost 800
prisoners that were held in Guantanamo
the United States has never been held to
account noted easily someone's being
prosecuted not even for unlawful
killings of prisoners that in the United
Kingdom there has been an agreement that
was reached between ourselves the four
Montana prisoners and the British
government in terms of us out of court
settlement shatters case was also part
of that out-of-court settlement so
essentially he's already been exonerated
by the government they just simply
didn't negotiate his release back and
that would happen back in 2010 so you
know for all intents and purposes he's
already exonerate as we are okay very
interesting now I mean back the Bush
administration and then the Obama
administration said that he could be
released to saudi arabia in in your view
in his and and the the various charities
and organizations that have been acting
first Shakur did the British government
at that stage do enough could they have
done more well of course they could they
could have done a lot more because
Britain has the United States have that
special relationship after all let's
remember that many other countries had
negotiated the release of their
prisoners for example Afghans
Mauritanians Turks and sofas were all
released to their countries of origin
and in some cases they had been
residents amok were not initially
citizens like the case of Morocco laws
in Germany for example but in Jacques
case actually he should have been
released a lot earlier the fact that
he's a Saudi citizen make is neither
here nor they was given leave to remain
in the UK his wife is British his
children are all British
raised and there's a right for that for
the husband to be with the wife for the
father to be with the children that
under the protections given under the
various conventions of by the United
Nations and others for the family not to
be separated Mo's I'm just finally I'm
do you intend to be part of any
welcoming committee or any group that
will be offering help to check on his
return um i already have been and what
i've done so with many of the Guantanamo
prisoners all around the world and in
the UK in particular so I hope that once
he's released in return I hope the first
he's giving the time and space to be
with his family and then when it's
required of me or anybody else who can
help then I'll absolutely do whatever I
can do to do moazzam begg thanks for
speaking to us here at Sky News